Scott Galloway說,中國的AI模型價錢只要美國頂尖模型的三十五分之一。
他認為這是傾銷,矽谷撐不了多久。
Galloway在紐約大學商學院教航銷寫過《四騎士主宰的未來》。
2019年WeWork準備上市,他公開說那個估值撐不住,一個多月後上市案就撤了。
這集是他的Podcast
9月3號上架
來賓Josh Tarungio是大西洋月刊的記者
剛出了一本書叫AI for Good
講中國之前
兩個人先談了一個聽起來很極端的主張
政府把AI公司收歸國有
Tarungio說喊這件事的人裡面有兩個名字
Bernie Sanders是自稱民主社會主義者的參議員
Steve Bannon是川普第一個任期的白宮首席策略長
兩個人站在美國政治的兩頭
在GPT 3.5推出後,我和Sam Altman談論了,我們談論了早期的2023年。
我對他說,這似乎很厲害,政府應該接受嗎?
他說,很可笑你這麼說。
在2017年,
我去各種地方的政府購物公司購物,
說:"我們認為你可能想要國際化,
但沒有人聽到。
我說,哦,那太有趣了。
所以讓我按摩一下,老闆,這對我來說似乎是壞話,是這樣嗎?
所以我,聽著,我不會用人家的語言來說AI的世界,因為 hype cycle。
我做了一些報告,我特別去了DOD。
DOD說他們沒有聽過,他們沒有聽過Sam Altman,他們知道他是誰,但他們沒有有這種討論。
我認識了一個在總統領導職位中的人
他說:"是的,這可能有發生過。
我說:"哦,好的。
現在,我在2017年,我並不負責任何人
說我們不會互聯網主義
因為我們根本沒有證明你所談論的證據。
我所說的這些例子,
是來自互聯網主義的人,
互聯網主義敵人,包括伯尼·桑德斯,
包括史蒂夫·班農。
因為他們感覺,
我認為這是在人材討論討論討論的很重要的一部分,
他們的缺乏信心,
我們的能力作為一個討論討論討論系統的系統,
導致他們對這種很極端的想法,
就是我們不會能夠做到的,
所以讓我們坐在會議席上,
讓我們把這些企業,
你知道,
史蒂德·曼登想要把這些企業的50%都坐在會議席上。
現在,我認為這是很多的。
我認為這是現代美國文化中無法預測的,
但是這是一個非常有趣的想法
它一直在發生
我們不會能夠管理這些公司
也非常擔心
that may be negative
我想我們可以更加細緻地說
我們會將它國際化
but maybe we're not
Galloway接著拿原子彈來比
美國當年做原子彈的曼哈頓計劃
從頭到尾是政府出錢
軍方在管
帶領實驗室的科學家就是奧本海默
是的,
這個想法比起似乎更不瘋狂,
因為如果你相信AI的主要經紀人和創建者認為這種技術比核心炸彈更強,
把他們的產品賣給LVMH
賣他們的核心炸彈到法國
這很明顯
你對的
我認為這太晚了
無論是Sam Maltman
和所有這些人
和他們的愚蠢的論點
制度我們
記得Cheryl Sandberg
說他們開放了制度
而在此時
佔領了百萬
若非千萬的律師
在制度上的任何事情上
在某種程度上,我們可以在最低限度上制定它們,甚至甚至做一些瘋狂的事情,例如有一個60天的持續期,
在那裡有一個非常詳細的青色紙紙團,包括你自己,經濟學家,技術家,
並將這些東西打開,並且將它們放在公眾面前。我們甚至沒有這樣的方式。
我們沒有這樣的方式,而且你提到核心,你知道,早在我開始宣傳這件事的時候,
當人們談論核心能力和人工智能時,你知道,我有一點討厭,對吧?
因為如果您正在推廣您的AI產品,
當然,
您可能會嚇唬一些人,
當您說,
不,
它能破壞世界,
但您也會激動一些人,
他們想要看到世界能破壞的軟件的回報。
但是我們實際上有國際核心制度,
它不是完美,
但它實際上成功了。
所以我們應該模仿什麼東西
在國際宇宙能力委員會上
你必須要宣佈你所持有的材料
你必須開放檢查
模仿某個尺寸的模型
必須通過國際制度公司
確認它們安全
而這一切都會死亡
我對這裡死亡有興趣
我們剛剛提到的那些人說
是的 但是中國
但是,中國是什麼?
這是一個不明確的說法,
我們只是假認我們知道中國想要什麼來自AI。
但是,我們是這樣嗎?
你知道,是有趣的,
川普和習近平
在春天的AI討論中,
他們第一次談論AI。
我認識的每個人,
寫和寫信,
認識中國,
都會告訴你一樣東西。
中國想要AI的東西,
就是中國想要其他所有的東西,
就是穩定性。
他們想要穩定性。
因此,
所以你有這兩個偉大的權力,
兩個都想要一樣的東西,
在全球上來說,
他們都想要擔任全球的事務,
AI是這樣的東西嗎?
你只能過來說,
最少我們兩個可以這樣管理,
我們沒有嘗試過,
但我們有一個挺成功的模式,
我聽過其他人談論,
中間聊
烏克蘭無人機的部分先跳過
Galloway接下來的論點
要先補兩段背景
第一段是傾銷
意思是用低於正常價值的價錢出口
通常是比在自己國內賣的還便宜
不一定有政府補貼
中國的鋼鐵就被美國跟歐洲這樣指控過
第二段是東京跟底特律
東京指日本車廠
底特律是美國三大車廠的大本營
1970年代石油危機之後
日本車靠省油跟便宜打進美國
三大車廠在本土的市佔
從將近九成掉到不到一半
2008年豐田的全球銷量超過通用
隔年通用跟克萊斯勒申請破產保護
我認為這是生產業最大的故事
它是與大量的AI浪費
與便宜的資金兌換
美國的CFO
越來越常提出
疑惑的問題
會選擇選擇比較低價的模式
例如Frontier的135價
而北京將在30週年內
進行到Silicon Valley
在30年之內做到的
你的看法是什麼
Tirangio的回答會提到蒸餾
這是一種訓練方法
拿別人的大模型當老師
大量對他提問
再用他的回答訓練自己的模型成本比從頭做低很多
絕對是有可能的
非常有可能
我還要提出一個詳細的問題
我們仍然不知道
均衡的分數
均衡的分數基本上就是
或者OpenAI推出了新的模型
我們預測它們會在
9個月到1個月前的中國人
在他們的精細性和模型的尺寸上
我們看到的就是它們快速地減少
而研究中的研究室
證明這些模型在中國
是被釋放或基本上被偷渡
你指IP偷渡嗎
對,它們只是普通的IP偷渡
我們從80年代以來
從中國的每個大企業都看過這件事
所以他們在供應方面,
他們實際上只是在搶賣他們的產品,
但是他們的能力在搶賣價值是很重要的。
我們看過中國的這篇文章,
我們看過它在阿富汗,
我們看過它在 Latin America,
他們將資產費用中國產品來轉移國家的價格,他們贏得了兩次。
所以,
一方面,
他們能夠獲得那些國家的文化、他們的數據,
他們能夠與他們聯繫的客戶聯繫很長時間的濃厚的環境。
另一方面,他們從美國公司取錢。
現在美國公司的問題是,他們真的沒有找到一個方法將他們的智能投資。
計算機的價格、能量價格都太高了
他們要做的東西對他們的客戶來說太差了
他們要把他們的客戶鎖在某個平臺上
很多CFO和CEO都說
我沒法承擔這些
尤其是現在
我相信你也聽過很多這些
當你和CEO聊天的時候
你會聽到有點像60年代的宣傳
現在人工智能是有用的,但那部分的交易是有用的嗎?
為什麼我的加密貨幣的價格那麼高?
為什麼我不能找到浪費的位置?
為什麼他們只能繼續走在屋頂上?
因此,無可奈何,當有人與一個相同的貨幣相似,或是10%更好的貨幣,
但價格是130,你將在那裡移動。
Galloway說
收歸國有已經來不及
美國現在連模型上市前
審議輪的機制都沒有
Terangio則認為
中國的低價模型
很快就會逼美國
拿出政治上的解法
原影片一個多小時
Terangio還講了
克里夫蘭診所的例子
醫院用AI預測敗血症
一年下來
院內的敗血症死亡率
降了41%
兩個人也談了
AI會不會搶走工作
他說經濟學家
在吵的是速度
電力取代蒸汽機花了40年
AI會不會只要3年
原影片連接在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多